[Music]
we're
rolling let me get a booger out
oh well let's take the plexiglass down
then yeah
i'll give it to you have you ever eaten
your boogers maybe when i was a kid but
i'm not
i'm not not into it the taste of it i
don't this is
i don't understand it but i know i'm not
gonna name names but i know
people that i respect that don't mind
the taste of their boogers that live in
this house
i know i'm like this is a list of three
people if it's someone you respect
it's not me that makes me very like i
don't think that's
very surprising i know of all of the
like personalities and vibes i've ever
gotten
someone would eat their boogers you're
right do you um
you do look like a booger eater and i
act like one too it's like it fits it's
recycling it's like
i think you look like i think you look
like a booger and an eater
we can name names i think we should i
can't name it well let's just i can name
names
let's just bleep it so we can continue
i'm not even gonna split but i'm not
even gonna
put that out there and trust the the
bleeping guys
i don't think they're eating is a crime
someone that's very very successful
this has to be something that esther is
so scared
that they could ruin her wait i have a
question
who you're gonna be like what are they
adult booger eaters or did they once
upon a time i'm so uncomfortable
with there's no further questions i can
tell you a booger eater i know
is it that i live with
of course he eats his boogers what is
that it's making me gag
can you just tell me like why or what
does he say about it like
let me get in the mind i don't
understand the appeal myself
but he says it's just something that him
and his brother have been drawn to their
whole lives
he doesn't actively pick his nose to
have a snack
but if it happens if it happens that he
has to pick his nose
and it always ends up it always somehow
ends up in his mouth
now maybe it's can i just guess maybe
his parents were very upset
finding swipes of boogers because i know
i had an old
roommate who would swear and i'll say
his name mike racine
i will say it loud and proud okay
he would dig into and then he would just
wipe like so next to his bed just had
like a just
it was like a little village of boogers
wait you've been roommates with men
several men yeah really yeah that seems
like
a dirty bathroom yeah it well it is i
mean it's a dirty bathroom for me
first of all i know they kept leaving
their dirty tampons everywhere it was
disgusting
like how much period blood could be on
this seat i do
and i have tasted my earwax you've taste
i've never it's never maybe accidentally
that's like less gross to me but it's
still
not something i'm gonna do there is
something i'd like to admit i'd like you
yeah we didn't think you would
you'd like your opinion on peta please
don't come after me
but i have um
chronic like ear problems because i was
a swimmer for a really long time
and sometimes i so i'm always like kind
of like
scratching at my ear kind of crying and
probing my ear
but when one time i took my finger out
and then all three cats
just like rushed over to my finger and
started
licking it like it was [ __ ] cat food
so now when i want to call them
i pretend like i'm digging into my ear
and i offer my finger and all three come
to me
that could be where i mean that's just
like being smart
that's not like i wouldn't call peta for
that do you
offer donut your panties no but that's
actually very surprising are you sure do
you want to do you want to consider the
question
i think about whether you want to be
honest or not i had a butt
i had a butt okay look
i use reusable pads and when it's my
time in the month
there's somebody in my household who
goes crazy for them
it's not my fiance
it's donut and she will do anything she
will drop
everything to get near my reusable pads
when she gets them do you call her
um a raspberry donut
she's like a jelly doughnut they're not
that like juicy
but look i will is that because they've
been like broken down over time
like each time you use them i get a
little less juicy
she donut will go up this is like a the
big problem my household is
her goal in life is to eat your brain
through your nose
so she's just always wanting to go up
the nose up the nose but it makes me
sneeze like crazy so
but sometimes dave will just be like all
right go up
go up all the way up like he's flailing
them open it's like he's
spreading his legs go all in i
so randy has just started
licking pee in a way that's like so
crazy like it's not like a lick here and
there it's like
he is like like pretty much eating out
p-spots of other dogs in the
neighborhood like i mean
really and then like like savoring it
like wiping it off like it's like
really it's sensual like he's so into it
and we were like we have to stop this
behavior it's so disgusting
and we looked it up and the articles
were like this is their natural way of
getting to know their neighbors you
can't
hinder this part of their like you have
to embrace it they're opening their
emails
they're it's their emails yes 100 it's
like he he's like leaving
comments he's he's liking people's
instagram posts
but it's really it's so disgusting and i
now am very much
i'm regretting the puppuccino challenge
hey guys
i'm annie letterman and i'm starting the
puppuccino challenge
which was by the way i still need to
you're in trouble
no i i bought the whipped cream i'm
ready to go wait who did you challenge
to do the party i challenged
okay so the puppuccino when you go to
starbucks a puppuccino you ask for a
puppuccino and they give you just
um some whipped cream does it cost money
i don't think they charge you for it
yeah
but they might can i have an ester chino
they charge 50 cents for water yeah they
probably maybe for the cuff
water they do i don't think that's true
i must have been really ugly that day
they couldn't spell your name they're
like litter's gonna charge you because
we don't want to try to spell your
[ __ ] name on this cup
for esther i told esther that i had put
some whipped cream in my mouth and had
randy eat it out and she's like you have
to do the challenge so i do the
puppuccino challenge
i make the video i challenge
esther i challenge whitney and i
challenge
joe rogan i think olivia muntu but i
really
was expecting i thought everyone would
do it and
i'm shocked no one's doing it whitney
hasn't even acknowledged it like whitney
is like you might need to like push it
on people's radar i'm gonna do it i
i will do it within the next 48 hours
and it's it is for a good cause it's to
fight against bestiality don't bang your
dog
ooh my mouth is watering thinking of
donut's little tongue
but see mine doesn't because it's a
little extra lemonade you're getting in
there
randy i mean he is just it's not like if
it was just like a lick it'd be fine but
it's
like he's like mouthwash he's like
gargling with it so you don't like when
your dog licks your mouth
it well i've seen what he's doing with
his mouth like it's
it doesn't it does not change anything
for me i've seen my dogs basically like
doggy centipede each other and i will
still
tongue them down every day i don't care
i don't care i eat [ __ ]
of anyone anything anyhow any [ __ ]
animals no [ __ ] uneaten
it just doesn't really you know it's
they're to me
so far in my 36 years of existence
i mean maybe this is why i have ibs and
some colon issues
but i'm not going to attribute it to
like licking my not
not licking my dogs but receiving kisses
from my dog i have a question
when you poop are there any like
wiggling worms in there i had worms when
i was younger
i thought all kids had worms yeah did
you have worms yeah
for sure really i think that might be
like a philippines thing yeah i think it
might be a third world country thing
no every kid is not a skokie thing i
remember when your mom had to check your
duty for worms yeah
that's like a thing annie you've never
been dewormed and you just never nobody
checked
i still have those it's like an 80-foot
tapeworm just
like it wasn't a hemorrhoid the whole
time it's just been a worm oh god
it's like scary they're like they're
alive they're like your pets
i had the thing
[Laughter]
they're like pets by the way i had crabs
i felt similar that is like pets in
junior high
i once i this is i always wanted like a
guy to give me his
sperm and like i always felt like you
could see it in a cup
and i could like you want to say it
wiggle yeah like i wanted it as a pet
but you know i'm gonna esther that's not
weird at all i once
took a chow mein noodle okay
i once took a chin chinese a chow mein
noodle
happy chinese new year by the way so
much um i once took a chow mein noodle
i put a little string around it and i i
it was my pet for three weeks his name
was jerry
it dried up it didn't jerry was my
my love and the the greatest thing to
happen in my life and then one day
it was a noodle and i wasn't four years
old
i was 12. and that's what happens when
you get molested
did you not have access to toys i did
have barbies who i
meant i added menstruation to the
barbies i was just a really really wait
was it a [ __ ] no it was a noodle you
should have just raised one of your
[ __ ] worms fight it
made like an ant farm for it traded to
fight
that's what you guys did in the
philippines it was instead of [ __ ]
fighting no we did spider fighting
you do like um what's that we put we
um get these spiders called kaka and we
put them on a stage i have to say
something and i don't want to sound
racist but everything is named kaka
no the other one is coco
my name is lyla
yeah you put two spiders on a stick and
then they fight to the death and then
whoever
uh if you own that spider you win money
are you serious yeah fight to the death
normal spiders yeah and then they wrap
their spiders that you like
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah well that's
just our childhood like hobby we collect
we have spiders we put them in a
matchbox we give them a little drop of
milk and a little place to sleep
and then we fight them with the neighbor
kids that's esther's dream to be treated
like that spider
she just wants a little drop of milk to
be in a little matchbook
that's so true well i played with we
used to play with little slugs and
worms i loved worms growing did you
relate to the
slugs they raised me and they
raised me to be the woman i am today but
raised by slugs i'm
i'm caught up on spiders will attack
each other like so if i
find two spiders in my yard can they
just take care of themselves if i put
them together
no i think these were specific types of
spiders yeah they were called
you couldn't just pull any random spider
because then you imagine you pull a
tarantula to fight a tiny little
of course it's going to eat it there's
no like loose tarantulas in california
yeah they're oh my god i need to take
you to azusa canyon
oh my god so we're
at 3 a.m one of these nights we're gonna
drive up azusa canyon
and it's going to be pitch black and
you're just going to do this you're
going to have a flashlight and you're
just going to
pick any point on the wall or the rocks
pick
any point and there's going to be at
least 30 40 tarantulas shut up
i swear to god i swear to god yourself
you don't because they don't do anything
they're harmless sleep with their mouth
open
and i'm sure you're a mouth open sleeper
of course i
am though on that plane i always look
like
my parents are gonna have to decide
whether they need to unplug me
it's so embarrassing i know i'm not
famous because that's never been posted
by anyone
it's so bad it's so incriminating do you
help people out when they're sleeping
with their mouths open
if it's a homie and he's sitting next to
you in a plane you go like
no if it's my friend it's posted i mean
if it's my friend
yeah you're ruined you're done maybe
you'll go viral you get some followers
one time i was on a flight and the guy
behind me was asleep the whole time
and he was doing the same snoring that
dave does
like the morning
[Laughter]
did you slip him your number and after
after the we landed
i was like sir like i don't want to
impose but you're gonna die in your
sleep
you need a cpap immediately i was like
do you know you have sleep apnea and he
was like i do and i was like okay good
i'm like i know those snores anywhere i
like that he was probably like i
hopefully i didn't bother around the
plane then he he's like oh confirmed yes
once you're on the plane though bother
away how does that work then if dave
let's say
you guys are flying to japan on a
16-hour flight like this
you've tried to get out of it then you
realize he'd have to push you around in
a wheelchair and you thought oh wait a
second
this is becoming a dream vacation
imagine if that were to have happened
so um he can fall asleep without his
mask
he takes lots of naps he's always tired
because of sleep apnea
and he just do you think it's just sleep
apnea or maybe
the upkeep of the upkeep so
he'll just breathe like really bad in
his sleep when he doesn't have the mask
what we in when we first started dating
he slept over my place one night
and i'm like oh it's fine like i'll be
fine with it it was the worst sign of my
life to be with him
all night through when he doesn't have
his mask how did the girl that lived in
the same room as you feel
the grown woman who also lived in that
room feel
was she kept awake i'm trying to
remember if she was there that night i
mean the fact that she might have been
is so crazy
it was one room it wasn't like a one
bedroom it was a
[ __ ] studio this is amy right yeah
amy
yeah she actually we have to do an
exchange she has some of my tax
documents
if you look to your left and right can i
guess what this is called is it a
cuckoo well
now usually it's a lot of money right
well this is our first chinese new
year's together so
what does this say that's basically
prosperity and
wealth covet dollar
oh and it's the year of um the ox
oh my god you guys snored so much
adderall with this do you guys know your
chinese zodiacs no but my dad calls me
the ox
um i'm a dragon you i know you are a
dragon how do you know
are you sure you didn't say you're
shaped like a box
[Laughter]
dragons are i think the only solitary
what why is everybody laughing at me
annie
you're 1983 you're a pig i don't know
guys
i'm not only a pig but in the in zodiac
too
i'm the 69 symbol i'm a crab
you are a water borer water pig
i'm a water pig you are um i don't know
what kind of dragon i think you're an
earth dragon
1980 yeah 1988. tell what do we need to
know
um there are certain things that i read
up on about each of the personalities
and they just didn't match either of you
so i didn't want to discredit
what are you i am a wood rat
you're a rat so jealous but 2020 was a
year of the rat and that didn't really
bode well for a lot of people did it
i'm not blaming 2020 for this 2021's not
that much better it's like i don't blame
the year yeah
yeah i'm not on board with the like the
year is bad like we got
because that then you just you like let
the year be bad yeah buttons to not try
to like take your
take the year by your own hit your own
pause and also it's like it has been bad
for everyone
esther by the way has been trying to
quarantine for years this has been like
a perfect time for her
i've enjoyed staying home a little bit
it hasn't been terrible i think if
you're it's been really it was tough for
extroverts because i have one of my best
friends is a huge extrovert
and she was dying does she know about
face time she was dying it wasn't enough
for her she needed to be around
people she needed to be around the
physical
touch and the energy she is single now
yeah but her dude broke up with her
during like very early on in quarantine
oh
he knew that he wasn't going to be able
to keep up with her need
he was like this is going to be rough
yeah but he was the deadbeat not her
well he found a comfier bed
guys we live in california there are
enough brush fires going on here
we don't need any more and that's just
when i wear corduroys
i don't have a thigh gap if you are a
man you are
a lover someone who cares about your
woman
for the love of god for the love of god
please purchase manscape are you guys
sick of your girlfriend sending your
sausage bag because she found a hair on
it
get a manscape the perfect package 3.0
is a perfect package for
his perfect package if you know what we
mean
giant that's why this revolutionary
company manscaped has redesigned the
electric trimmer and called it the
lawnmower
3.0 their lawnmower 3.0 has proprietary
advanced skin safe technology so this
trimmer reduces cuts on your man's nuts
if you love the d just as much as we do
then it's time to get yeah
is that your gargling balls oh my god
why do you have to make it explicit
i didn't have to be there
you're the gargoyle it's a suggestive
gargle it was
very obvious you guys get 20 off with
free shipping with the code bloodbath at
manscape.com
ladies this is the perfect gift for you
and your man trust me he will thank you
and men your balls will thank you too
and you may be thinking
yeah i've heard of manscaped i'm on the
fence now
is the time do it for the bloodbath
babes
we love it and we know you will too and
nothing has to be explicit about that
this is very suggestive and gentle and
these products smell nice their manly
scent
is attractive and will help spice up the
mood this right here is a crop reviver
and it's a refreshing ball toner you
just spritz and go on with your day
this deal is actually really good i'm
jewish so i know i can say that with
clout
um you can get 20 off plus free shipping
with code
bloodbath at manscape.com that's 20
off with free shipping at manscape.com
and use the code bloodbath
thank you manscape for making our sex
lives
way better george can we pull up the
traits of the dragon and the waterboard
please
waterboard waterboards earth dragon and
waterbore
i'm a wood rat that's close enough to
hoodrat
that's cool though yeah i was a i wasn't
but you're not a rat manny's is one
letter away from waterboard
and you love waterborne i love to
waterboard
it's so close to what i want to do to
esther here we go
what are you guys oh that is such an
esther looking dragon too look at that
[ __ ] esther ass dragon
it's two feet tall mysterious
imaginative
and ambitious oh i love
that's me i swear mysterious i
swear i'm imaginative i love to go home
and sit with my toys and
imagine all sorts of scenarios oh my god
this is her role-playing coach by the
way
all of her toys are of the sexual kind
they are not
a lot of butt plugs guys let's go
straight to weaknesses okay
can any you want to take over okay oh no
i'm not gonna read it
it's too much they often they often seem
to be in a daze
and look elusive most of the time
sometimes the dragon personality of
arrogant
of arrogance keeps people away from them
because of the good luck some of them
may become less industrious and that may
result in failures
i mean laughs from the side are pretty
good in that moment
they are strict listen to this they are
strict with subordinates
yeah oh um um excuse me you pretending
right now that this is not
if people make mistakes in work they
criticize them relentlessly
although they are eager to succeed they
can be frustrated by
setbacks easily and they are likely to
give up halfway
i feel like that's not true because i
don't think that i'm really open to
setbacks
i am very comfortable with setbacks they
just
come with that i'm good um
let's see i do like that they said days
and you do look like the days in
confused kid which we've talked about
already
let's go to um waterboard george
waterboar let's see is it here that's no
that's really cute waterpoor is so cute
i love pigs i'm jealous if there was a
competition to name the nicest people in
the world
water pigs would walk it okay year in
and year out they don't have a single
malicious
negative nasty trait in their posts
that's true
okay we're all just gonna pretend that
that's right
they are vulnerable though they're so
laughably sensitive it would be comedic
if it were not such a burden to these
happy souls
a happy soul water boars or happy souls
oop emily blunt it's so funny
i don't want any of these celebrities
wait they're not workaholics they're
chilled as helen would happily spend 23
hours a day in
bed yeah [ __ ] yeah that's right guys
out there [ __ ] hoenn
the creative output and overwhelmingly
charming personas
more than make amends oh guys it is
for so you spend all day in bed but you
are
charming and people like that i think
that's that's a good deal
so i got through college i already know
everything about a wood rat
so let's not excuse me well what will
you tell us
it just i don't think it matches
anything i think that rats are very like
industrious beings and i think that i'm
not
like a type a like that hmm do you ever
wish you were type a
no because type a people drive me
[ __ ] crazy really yeah i respect it
and i need them to be around me
but never close to me like never that
close
it just seems like it stresses me out
they're never happy it's like doesn't
seem like there's a happiness there's no
end to what they're doing
i see maybe that's good maybe you're
like you're kept busy
so you're not i'm really jealous like i
wish i was type a
i feel like that means you just get
everything done you're organized the
trains are on their tracks at all times
yeah my i one of my sort of close
friends is a
type a to the t and she planned a
platinum
wedding all by herself and it
she headed out of the park so there are
i understand why type a's are absolutely
necessary
did she have fun at her wedding or was
she trying to keep everything
i couldn't tell i feel like i don't have
fun
i had a lot of fun at her wedding you
know so
thank you for her type a personality
because it was an amazing wedding
yeah because i do feel like if you're
yeah if you're just always trying to
make everything per
i don't know what is the definition of a
type a
personality can we figure that out no i
think it's somebody who
is um organization
um punctuality follow-through people who
like go
now i wouldn't even say go-getter
because you can be a lazy you know like
you could be
not a type b and not be and still be a
go-getter okay at first i didn't know
there was type b
so good to know um so type a is
competitive
time urgent hostile and aggressive yes
maybe i am type a
i didn't know that you just have that
part
or type b is relaxed patient and easy
going i'm neither of these
yeah is there a type c i've never met
like a true well
i guess you're patient i am i am
definitely a type b
yeah you are that's trained patients
though
i feel like i had the
that inside me where i wanted to be it
but i had none of the follow through so
then i was just like this overachieving
underachiever just so miserable all the
time
nothing done that's common but with um
with comedy is when i was like oh i just
was like i'm gonna do the most when i
first started i was like i'm gonna do
the most open mics and just
that was like the only thing i hustled
at i feel like that's just you finding
an absolute
your passion you have to want things
yeah to like really want it
i think my thing is i i'm just i'm not
lazy i'm just like fatigued all the time
so like i always want to accomplish and
i and i
do and i keep but it's like so hard for
me i
struggle you know what i think it is too
because my mom did this too our parents
would like come in and kind of like do
the things if we were too tired or
whatever
i see you always say your mom did your
homework my parents never did my
homework
i was i definitely like had to do my own
homework but my mom
just kept it like the house clean like
that's why i can't do these basic things
it's like very painful for me to put my
plate away but like your brain
probably gets fatigued because you're
like this is what i do to like get out
of this thing do you know what i mean
you like become fatigued it's like
you're real like i also it might have to
do with like my headache problems i
don't know
maybe you're right like my dad is always
like oh yeah
let me guess you have a stomachache
you have chronic fatigue syndrome and
it's just an umbrella term for all of
these things that you're describing and
it's a real thing
how do i cure it i don't think there's a
cure for it because sometimes i do feel
that but then i think i attribute mine
to
depression and so especially when i hit
a dip
and which happens like a couple months
out of the year i
cannot do anything i can't even put a
plate away and
from the outside looking in people are
like oh no like she gets things done but
there are days where
i am useless i don't want to pick up a
phone to speak to anybody i don't really
want to turn on the lights nothing i'm
just i'm just
i'm out sound like a real water borer
[Laughter]
how do you get through those days um so
when i was younger i was
on a lot of medication and i had a
really bad experience with them so i
don't
i have a really good understanding about
my cycling
patterns now when i'm gonna dip when i
come back
up and i write it out when i'm up here i
can do everything and i am in control
when i'm down here i don't answer there
calls
texts nothing i am down in the dumps and
how long does that last
um this last time i just kind of sort of
crawled out of it
two weeks ago um but it lasted about
two months what and when you say you
write it down and you're like conscious
of your cycles that does
like you have a schedule like you know
it's about to hit again yeah so a lot of
times for me it's seasonal
my family knows it already they know not
to expect too much out of me like during
you know when i'm really down here it's
that's pretty convenient then you don't
have to do any like the thanksgiving
stuff
the christmas stuff oh i thanksgiving
yeah i can handle that [ __ ] i'll show up
on christmas i still i i do everything
for christmas like big
not begrudgingly but very tiredly yeah
fatigued
but fatigued but it's it it can be that
or you know
it could be just uh you know do you have
low blood pressure
i do how'd you know because that can be
it's a vibe i do
i do what's up george uh it's about time
uh kyle's ready for the phone call
oh my god oh my god fatigue's the
perfect time oh no
okay hi kyle it's kalylah
hey how are you i'm good you're on the
show
with um with myself annie and esther
and first i just want to say that i am
so sorry that we called you out on
um on what episode of tiger belly was
that george
uh i think was that 280.
the teacher and annie had just so
happened to call me and she's like why
are you in a bad mood i was like
this teacher was so mean she was like
i'm shaking she's not gonna like i'm
shaking
i'm gonna believe what just happened to
me i just left barry's boot camp like
they were verbally abusive to me it was
really weird
and then annie i was like it's a you
just paid 35
to go to an hour-long boot camp class
where they yell at you that's
the exact thing you just paid for that's
the entire thing
and she made me feel better because i
was like it could have only been one
instructor and it could have only been
kyle
it yes it was kyle and i only pay for
kyle who's kyle that exact experience
that you you
wanted to write a karen letter about is
the exact experience i would pay extra
for
he's so mean he was so wonderful
that i really love your workouts and um
i've never i miss them so much and they
remind me of the best times of my life
the best period of my life oh my
i i god having you i'm so happy that you
love the workout and listen i i don't
think i'm for everyone clearly i'm
not for esther but i'm happy that you
and annie are
feeling it and love the experience well
here let me pass this
now i'm glad that you called esther by
her real name and not her nickname the
jellyfish
is it okay if i pass you to annie yeah
oh yeah here hang on one sec
all right hey kyle it's annie here um
i'm looking i'm looking at esther's weak
weak face right now
she's scared and maybe a good friend
would say
be nice to her but this isn't a show
about good friends this is about
bloodbath so
i anything
just get let me all right i'm passing
you to esther i'm just saying you have
my brush
push-ups i love how when annie talks to
him she turns on like
sexy voice i think i just have a sexy
voice i think you're just attracted to
me
okay hi hi kyle hi
hi kyle hey hon how are you i'm good
i just wanted to say a few things okay
i just i'm going to start by saying i'm
actually really jealous
of the relationship you and kalyala have
i wish
that i had the experience she has
with your classmates or kyle yeah but
i'm
weak and i think the problem is i just
wasn't ready for your
class and i had no business being there
but i like the music that you played
[Laughter]
i don't know how to resolve this but i
want this i want to make things right
between us
i want to make things right too i think
that i think our relationship can really
grow from here
you know what's so funny esther's gonna
have to go to your workout now um
you said right me um yeah i go
on and off i during the class she goes
on and on
can you do some jump squats for me and
i'll walk you through it
i think that's a good idea right now
jump squats uh-huh
right now like jumping jump squats here
i'll show you
like jumping like moving your body
jump squat okay do you know how to do a
jump squat
yes i know how to do a squat here i'm
going to jump at the end
i'm going to hand the phone is jump and
squat too much to us
but kyle isn't jumping bad for your
knees oh
kyle kyle get her kyle get her
how about a plague can you playing no
she doesn't have a judge i'll do the
jump squat
jump squat she doesn't have abs okay
yeah that's what i need you need to do a
swimming exercise you got to learn how
to swim but kyle i i do need to learn
awesome kyle what's your advice for me
like how can i get stronger well show us
the jump squat trick
do what he says no but i first want kyle
to tell me his
squat i need the advice to give me
feedback okay okay
okay fine okay fair enough fair enough
passing you off wherever
make sure that your knees are behind
your toes and you actually have to
get off of the ground okay okay
i'm handing the phone to annie so i can
get up and hold on hold on annie
i have a great system guys esther were
you hoping that he was gonna like
um tell you a machine you could use on
your abs no i was hoping that he was
going to be like
you can do it slow and steady okay
okay here we go esther is about to do a
jump squat
at least eight eight jump squats
you're going to use your arms to propel
you upwards so when you jump your arms
actually go
down next to your thighs so when you're
jumping uh-huh
you got it esther yes one oh my god my
knee
oh my goodness there's a thing between
us but she would be pushed so far
forward right now by me
[Applause]
two this is our second one but esther
come up from the squat
ready honey yeah my god that's her
favorite line
she really is struggling i have to say i
start you're
supposed to go up with your butt you
don't just keep jump in the position of
a squat
yeah so extend all the way
here hold on let me show you you're
squatting and then
yes what was i doing you were going like
this
you were maintaining your kyle we're
still at number three
okay four five
i mean the arms are just flailing
sick oh she looked there was a leap back
on that one why are you laughing so hard
i want to know what's so funny pick up
the pace
it's fine you'd already be back on the
treadmill by now
no she'd be leaving i should be getting
her smoothie
you did it esther you did eight wow i
can't wait for kyle to see this
okay okay kyle tell kyle at some point
he has to review
the footage yeah it's not going to be
good for you i felt
i feel my thighs my thighs and my butt
are burning
here i'm going to give you back to
esther
okay
hey kyle how are you doing or do you
need cpr
[Laughter]
i'm doing a good you know i never would
have elected to do those
uh jump squats but
i i'm glad i did it what they're the
first for everything yeah
i'm glad i did it she is sweating and
out of breath which is
shocking for the amount of effort i just
saw putting
to really move forward and create this
strong bond together
we just need to recover from the past
and really just be open and honest
okay so what can i do for you how can i
better help you and
what did i say that really made you cry
in your car i'm so sorry
okay so i didn't really cry um but i was
really
like almost like low
like i was like really down in a sad
mood
and i didn't want to admit to it but
thankfully annie had called me
and she was like what's wrong i was like
uh
and then you know she i told her the
teacher was mean to me
and she said that's what they're
supposed to do and then it made me feel
better
um i think look i think
now here's my question
can i have a wheelchair if i've gone i
guess i'm just curious like if you have
advice for someone like me who's weak
but wants to be strong
my advice would be to actually try
and then i can really help you from
there so
walking on the treadmill is acceptable
at some point
but you can also walk outside for free
so if you're paying 35
one would at least try to jog you know
yes
think about money who's getting you he
knows you're jewish
um listen it's all about effort you're
never competing with like
anybody else in the room but as long as
you're really trying
then like usually i have no issues okay
okay
okay i thought maybe like maybe i was
mean to you because you were on your
phone or something
no no no no no not me not me no i there
i've been there when there's the people
on their phone
no not never me i'm not like that yeah
okay well i still appreciate that i'm
all for like
people really trying and like as long as
you're being respectful of the state
it's like
we're friends okay okay
well he has an outdoor class sometimes
there's not really
century city maybe we can all come take
your class he only offered to
um give me a free class
offering on me okay i mean we can we'll
have to do some
bring some cameras okay well i'm going
to hand you off to
kala but kyle thanks so much i really
appreciate
you kyle i'm so disappointed in you
annie she's not crying you haven't
yelled at her
okay thanks carl here's kalila
hey kyle i was really hoping you'd go
after her harder
because i fee but you know what um
i feel like um there could be a really
blossoming relationship here between you
and esther
he's gonna be giving her rides in no
time driving her
class sometimes the best relationships
start off a little bit
that's true that's true esther and i
will say here's the one thing that i
did love most about you kyle is that you
were never mean to
one person unless they were on the phone
or just up to [ __ ]
if you were gonna say anything i
consider like what
it's not mean but challenging it was
directed towards everybody
not just you never singled anyone out
and i really like that about
you oh my gosh well i love that you had
that experience
and like loved the class and missed the
class but
yeah i mean i'll come for anyone no one
is really off limit
well we can't wait to see you what's
kyle's inside
i'm so happy that i got to connect with
you it's been too long
awesome kyle we'll see you soon awesome
all right bye y'all
bye bye i mean esther's like i have a
neck problem she's whipping her hair
around after the
exercise no i have injuries i
look i how do you feel first how was
that like very um
because you were you legitimately were
out of breath it seems yeah no that's
hard for me especially
jumping because jumping is hard on your
knees
some say um i feel
like i would love honestly it all goes
back to the first sentence you said to
him when you were like
i miss the memories of your class i felt
so
strong like that reminded me of growing
up and taking a dance class and like
feeling like yes like that good feeling
afterwards and i'm like oh i want to
have that experience with kyle's class
i do maybe you need to take dance
classes yeah if there wasn't covet i
probably would
but maybe it's just not because it's a
[ __ ] boot it's an actual
like their whole thing is they yell at
you but like that's my dream i want to
be that strong but i'm just not and
maybe
maybe it's something i can aspire slowly
but surely
i think you surely it would be a good
name for you as an elderly woman
sure ah do we need a banana break after
that george
[Music]
what does esther get instead of banana i
actually brought something unless george
has a special treat for me i'm open
we should get those japanese uh treat
boxes
what are they i need botox i used to
have kaiser and i was one of their
[ __ ] botox guinea pigs for my armpits
they used to be yeah tell me your girl i
want to go kala i have a i have a nurse
question
is it botox for tmj yes um
you know i my
um doctors says that
there have been people who only do it
once and it sort of trains them to not
it forces them to not be able to like
clinch down because that's your problem
right
and then they don't ever have to do it
again but i do know that if you do it a
lot you're going to lose bone density in
your
yeah i was supposed to do a study um
these are raw bananas
all right chris you're getting fired i
told him specifically ripe bananas
gave him two days to find him it's
barely even a banana
if those extra bananas are going to go
wasted i will take them home to my air
fryer
just putting them oh that's right that's
your new thing i'm sorry i'm sorry i'm
sorry avocado oil on banana
into an area doesn't eat bananas unless
they're
fried not gonna lie to you esther they
didn't look great
on instagram but i'm sure they tasted
delicious because anything
anytime you fry banana it's amazing it's
so if esther made it i'm guessing it's a
little bland
something's missing air fried banana
is so easy and so good you would like it
i mean it was such a hard no on bananas
that i'm really
i'm gonna i'm gonna try it but not with
these
um bananas i'm gonna try them with
because they're cooking bananas they're
saba bananas or plantains that are
way better for cooking than these i
didn't know that
my face is gonna be swollen just in time
for tomorrow's photo shoot
tomorrow's photo shoot is nobody's happy
about it no thank you
nobody wants this to happen but we'll
just do it and then for people who don't
know
we're taking photos together tomorrow
and i've tried to get out of it
every day this week not one person wants
to do it but it's like we kind of have
to do it
i disagree i don't think we have when
should we do it then
i don't think we ever have to do it no i
think we should do it at some point
you guys are not why do you not want to
do it i just don't like f like i just
always always have anxiety
over taking photos i just um have just
gained so much weight and i know i look
fine but it's like it's just
it sucks when you're like let's uh
immortalize this time in my life when i
have just been packing it on
i'm right with i this is the problem
when i knew that we had to take pictures
on saturday you know we talked about
this
you should not tell yourself not to eat
because then that's all you do right you
make it sad and then you're like oh the
bad thing
every day like a [ __ ] garbage
disposal i'm just like
shoving [ __ ] in my mouth that's why i
don't i have
eliminated that from my life of like oh
don't eat today because you're taking
pictures later like
even clayton was coming over one day to
take pictures and i was like
oh i'm about to eat like a big bowl of
pasta he's like well why don't you just
have it after and i was like
nope because even just him saying that
like got me
like i probably ate a little more
because of it like i cannot
tell myself not to eat that is the devil
of like that you'll just eat
i've never i've never been a not eater
that's never it's
never worked ever in my life not once
that's just never where my brain goes
and i guess i'm very lucky because of
that but
yeah it is just that i was saying to
kalyan the other day it's like
whenever i'm like i'm going on a diet
tomorrow i have like a going-away party
for the food you know i'm like oh
let's have a throw a cake a going away
party and then i shove
so much cake in my mouth that i wake up
so sick the next day that i'm like
the only thing that's gonna make me feel
better is more cake and then i just
eat cake for five months well that's
what happened to me over the holidays
i ate cake for five straight days and i
went deaf
and that's how i knew i needed to turn
my life around
i was in the shower and my i just lost
my hearing what it was like
and i was like oh this is it the sugars
have gotten to me i
straight up went deaf for 30 seconds
from eating sugars for five straight
days you know a couple years ago
i was into all the rhetoric about like
sugar is bad for you sugars but so it's
like i'm quitting sugar
so monday morning i wake up like i'm
quitting sugar and by
2 p.m i was at the grocery store pints
of ice cream at home and opening every
pint and if i
didn't say i was quitting sugar that day
i would have never
ended up with pints of ice cream i would
have just been normal
and so like ever since that experiment i
was like okay now i know
there's no there's i don't eliminate
anything i ca like i have to have it all
yeah oh i hate when you do that
esther you're turning into quite a
little salute online how are you feeling
about that
a salute you're growing you're gr you're
exposing more am i the shorts are
getting shorter
oh my cruise line outfit the tops are
getting cropped
i saw i saw abs i know underneath the
layers of
no no you don't know you actually
naturally have a good body which is
really really actually of all the people
in the world that should just look
so disgusting it's you
thank you you guys there's this thing
have you ever heard of the 36 questions
that lead to love
yeah you have george have you annie
i've heard of the 36 questions that lead
you out of love
so basically it's this idea that you can
take any two people
sit them across from each other and ask
these 36 questions can i
ask you a question yeah are you cold
no i think it's because my nipples were
pierced my nipples are always pretty now
i kind of know what like an
old man feels like when they're like you
know what your nipples are a distraction
you
acting like this is the first time
you've gawked at
my breasts the breasts around you this
is the first time you've known what it's
like to feel like an old man
this is oh speaking of which that
that um podcast um that you sent that
disaster
that says that you are actually in love
with your best friend
okay i this was a very
emotional experience for me there's this
podcast on the cut like
an episode and it's about this girl
who's like am i in love with my best
friend
because i guess her best friend moved
away during covid
and she was like really thinking she was
like crying every day since her best
friend left
and she was really sad when like got
depressed
and was upset like how their lives
weren't as intertwined anymore was
considering
moving to where her best friend moved
and she's like
wait like people move across country all
the time for like a romantic partner
but there's something weird about doing
it for just a friend and
she was just like exploring and she was
like i
here's what i really related to she was
like i want to have a sleepover with my
best friend i want to lay up all
night in bed together and talk oh my god
wait for them to fall asleep
first peel up the covers put my hand on
her pants
no no you can't no ann no no
no anne i know that was horrible that
was very upsetting
okay so i was like wait yeah
i when i think of my childhood best
friend like all i want to do is stay up
all night with her and talk and like
i want to live with her i'm like what is
this wait i have a question this is
christina
yeah okay so she just got married are
you jealous of her
were you pissed at her no not at all no
because they're so funny together are
there parallels between dave and
christina
no not really christina's her own
special thing
because i do believe this this um theory
of being
in love with your best friend and i
think that's exactly what i did my best
friend is
a korean girl who's very feisty who's
very funny
and when i first met bobby immediately i
was like oh i want him in my life
forever
really and yeah i and on top of that my
best friend had just had a baby
and um i her baby refers to me as
daddy like i make the baby refer to me
as
daddy like she calls me up
and i see her i'm like quinn it's appa
it's me so i do i do think that there is
and i love her i can't we've never not
lived in the same city
and i will never move she'll never move
my sister will never move because
we can't live without each other i'm so
jealous so maybe there is that
so yeah what do you feel towards your
best friend i honestly like
just fantasize just okay
doing nothing after when clovid's over
just doing nothing and her playing with
my hair
like that's the greatest thing that
could happen in my life right now is her
just coming over and just like
not even talking to me and just us being
lazy maybe we'll cook bacon and rice and
gorge that day as a water bore untouched
and then do nothing i want to be in a
room with her
and do nothing yeah that's love but
mine is not i don't really like the
touching like the hair
stuff pubes
[Laughter]
but yeah like that's that's interesting
like that's not i don't know would you
rather do that with her than with bobby
some days yeah yeah there are days where
i prefer
her company yeah and she dives with me
you know we go to the beach a lot
together would you muff dive
i can't think of her in like a sexual
way yeah it's not sexual right
it's not but it's a very emotional thing
no like i agree with you though when i
think of post covid the first thing i
want to do is like
go have a sleepover with my best friend
in her grandma's basement and then like
go to menards in the morning
like that's i just want to be with my
best friend like i don't want to like
see the world or anything i always feel
like my best friend and i would always
um we met in college and we were always
very like
there was this fantasy and this idea of
like somehow co-inhabiting like
having two houses on the same property
stuff like that
and but now it's like i can't imagine
her ever living in la and i don't want
to like live on a farm i like i
the farm idea is so like out of my head
but it is
and i think because i lived in such a
small town when i lived in santa fe so
many i would have like
my core friends would always move out of
town everyone was always leaving that i
kind of
got used to that sort of like heartbreak
of being long-distance best friends
how did you end up in santa fe um i just
really
i grew up in philly and then i just
wanted to go to a school i was wasn't
sure if i wanted to do
haven't be an art major or a teacher or
a education major and i
looked at a bunch of schools and i just
liked santa fe i thought it was fun when
i stayed there
and then i'd lived there for eight years
and got very drunk
and santa fe is like a really weird
place where you can just kind of pause
your life
but it sucks because when you leave
everyone else has kept going like
they're just the bar is very low
it's very it's just small town vibes it
was really fun
but definitely like everyone would move
away and you just had to like deal with
it
that sounds [ __ ] so depressing so
nice to just pause your life
for a year and like live in a small town
yeah well kovac kind of did that made
this into a small town
that's true do you guys want to go
through some of the 36 love
questions yeah i know that they get
progressively more
um um probey i guess
um but we should george do you want to
do you want to pull it up the 36 love
questions really just i want to go home
and do this dave so badly i
bobby and i are both cross-eyed imagine
two cross-eyed people staring at each
other for four minutes
come on work with it
okay here's set one these are the
lighter questions right it starts it
starts nice and
light given the choice of anyone in the
world whom would you want as a dinner
guest
it's already hard like my dad yeah i
don't know i wanna hang out with my dad
and alive presently i think lady gaga
would be interesting to talk to
you think that she'd be equally as
interested in you though or she would
just be like phoning it in just
she wouldn't be phoning it in she's not
like that she loves her fans
she wouldn't oh my god you'll do
something though don't worry you'll be
too much
she'll get fearful she'll get scared
she'll take away your sharp objects
you have to eat with your fingers annie
who who would you want to have
i don't like i don't sweat celebrities
like that i don't know i can't think of
like a celebrity i'd really want to hang
out with
um sweat celebrity i don't i don't i
don't i don't have like
i don't have like a like to me the idea
of hanging out lady gaga sounds
so unfun and like not something i would
want to do it would seem to me it sounds
i have zero questions for her i have
like i'm like where why are we she's
so artistic i love her but i would be
exhausted
thinking of how even what to ask her how
to like carry on conversation
that's just because i just i'm kind of a
hermit though
so i wouldn't i'd probably have dinner
um just with my sister and that would
make me the happiest person on earth
yeah i would love to be hanging out with
my dad my dad and i going to like a
diner would be really fun
before making a telephone call do you
ever rehearse what you're gonna say
and why not really because i've learned
that that will
that i'll mess that up anytime i go in
with like a strict plan for a call
i sound like i had a strict plan and
it's not going well
oh god i i was uh dealing with a car
accident and this lawyer was like just
call the company and say these things
and i was he like made me write it down
and i kept going rehearsing it with him
so much that he was like
i'm calling them for you it's fine he's
like you're gonna [ __ ] this up so bad
like
i just had so much guilt even though it
wasn't my fault in the accident i just
had so much like
guilt and felt so wrong that i was like
that he just was like you sound so
[ __ ] guilty he's like this is not you
did not do this you are not at fault
he's like i'm just doing it
because i couldn't and i had it written
down i just sounded like insane
but yeah i don't think anything i try to
go into things without
um like not being attached to the
outcome because i feel like if i it's
like
not a real conversation unless it's like
these are boundaries i have to set or
something and then i'll probably wait
like
five months before i have that
conversation
just avoid it have you guys seen that
tick tock that's going around where it's
like
they ha this resort somewhere this beach
resort has like
this plastic walkway that rides the way
oh yes i've seen that the dock
it looks the movable dock yeah it looks
scary that i'm like that to me is like
watching a horror film i'm like oh yeah
oh the thrill oh my god like i could
experience a wave
safely there we go esther the dock
kala what is your opinion of this this
doesn't seem safe at all i don't
understand how you could safely
experience a wave this way if you get
launched off that dock lose your balance
yeah that's wild that doesn't
you could easily lose your balance and
get so you would be
you'd be on all fours oh my god
the one i saw was way closer to shore we
would have to get a
[ __ ] helicopter to come get you oh my
god that does look so you would be
yeah you would be medevaced i could
never do that it looks like but it's
like giving me a thrill to look at it
because it's just like oh my god holy
[ __ ]
also though the way those waves are what
happens if you get
like fall into one of those waves you're
just sucked up let me tell you
let me tell you exactly how it feels to
get taken down by a wave it doesn't feel
great even coming from a swimmer it
doesn't feel great
but eventually it spits you back out and
you're fine really
yeah it's just like kind of like
tumbling for a little bit
but you know not to inhale the water
right
no i know that now well
you're not supposed to breathe regularly
as if you were on land you're supposed
to
hold your breath oh my god this is so
good what do you do in the shower after
a film teaching you to swim in a pool
she doesn't take showers she doesn't
even take showers i take baths
okay well do you ever dip your do you
ever like no
i told i thought i told you guys this
everybody had a party pool party
pressured me to go down the slide
and i went down the slide and i didn't
know that i was supposed to hold my
breath
and so when i fell into the water i just
breathed in
and i was thought i was dry drowning and
i told you guys that maybe it was on
facetime enough no i think
i think you said it on the show and i
said i popped up from the water and i
looked at dave and i said
ism gonna drown
and ever since then me and dave say that
now
a lot isn't gonna drown because i was so
afraid
i didn't remember how to speak right
okay that's
i i i don't even blame you because this
one time the microwave um
our old rinky tank microwave and our old
in our first american house blew up
and i panicked so hard i and i looked at
my sister and i said
what did it say
because i just didn't know what was
happening but i wanted to know what the
microwave i was like
what did it say but that's exactly it i
know that feeling esther but you know
what do you trust me
yeah do you trust that i'm a solid water
person and i wouldn't necessarily trust
yeah i would never never prey on your
fear of water i would never i would
respect
all of you hold you under until you
think you're
no longer going to leave me and he has
to be 20 feet away
listen i was a special ed teacher i'm
good with working with
special needs people oh my goodness well
it feels like is it about that time
uh should we call bobby yeah bobby has
um has a gift for all of us
for chinese new year oh oh my god
oh wow thank you that's a durian fruit
what yeah oh
fancy durian food has it ever been
living it looks like it was something
that was the live ones
yeah it was living i would get killed i
cut myself right here cutting it
come here babe come to me come to me and
um have you had durian
no come on to mike come on tonight
between mango and vomit
ew
[Laughter]
this right here is durian fruit and um
yeah yeah yeah let's just assume a mango
was in vegas
right he had no money and he prostituted
himself
to get a ticket back home i feel like a
mango is a girl bobby obviously
right and um it's basically if
you know a mango um could take a [ __ ]
that's what it is do you like it no i
[ __ ] hate it and it's why do you have
it
no oh yeah you're gonna eat it so well
listen
all right once a year my people have a
new year
okay so do my people right exactly right
and so um for me it's like it's
oh don't touch me well i'm describing
okay
[Laughter]
so um once a year my people um we
celebrate by
eating a durian fruit and um white
people
um are very much welcome and
um of course smell it if you if you can
i smell it from here it's
gonna smell it from closer oh you know
i'll eat it i'm down
i want to watch annie eat it no esther
you have to do it looks like
chicken
mango but then it goes foul it goes into
bad foot really soon look okay so i
annie you eat it oh it looks like
mustard oh no we need it we need
everybody to take a taste you know yeah
with your hands yeah grab something
my head army hammer this is like very
fleshy all right all right it smells
it smells like fermented yeah it smells
fermented eating it
look i'm from the philippines this is my
fruit and even i can't
eat it but i'm gonna do it today she's
eating it it's like a savory it tastes
delicious
of course to you annie i like it you do
yeah you spring your hand for look what
i i like
because of the [ __ ] durian [ __ ]
[Laughter]
i cut my [ __ ] up oh i want another one
yeah yeah
i don't know what just just take this
part it's the gizzard
the kids are not part of it
smells so bad give me more i want more
i'm spoiled
don't smell it just eat it it smells
like [ __ ] garbage
garlic [ __ ] eat it you eat garlic on
your [ __ ] sugar fish [ __ ]
it tastes like onion i don't like it
bobby i don't care it's my [ __ ]
people
all right hey give me more let me have
something over here it tastes like a
[ __ ] like slime
you know you're a super smeller esther
and it is pretty super small
it's pretty um way more than that babe
i'm sorry
babe listen to me i'm going double i
want one
babe eat a whole
oh i'm gonna throw up
the taste does stay with you for a while
then
[Music]
[Laughter]
this is what comes out of joy diaz's
dick
[Music]
you gotta take it away i can't deal with
it all right i'll take it okay take it
away
all right take it away
no no not near me
guys i genuinely liked it so look at my
face
completely i i like understand that you
guys don't have this experience
i've hated it since i was a kid who the
[ __ ] wanted to do that
it was my idea and it was it backfired
i knew annie would like it i [ __ ]
knew it
i genuinely thought you were gonna vomit
on the camera no i genuinely thought
that i was down for this because i'm
like
this is from my country right i should
be i should have a predisposition to
liking it
and i know that i i hated it growing up
but i just thought okay like
i'm an adult now i can eat and i can eat
anything by the way like i eat like
i eat anus i cannot eat a durian for the
rest of my life
that almost like you were really hurting
i was i'll never recover i'll never be
the same
i would rather eat bobby's anus
i do have a feeling they all taste very
similar
i you know what they don't bobby's anus
does is infinitely
infinitely less putrid so
that was our episode i do you want to
take your mask off i cannot take my mask
off because the [ __ ]
smell of that thing that you made us try
right here
maybe that's why i liked it it smells a
lot and tasted like my
hoagie armpits um but you guys thanks
for listening
and what do we say just subscribe smash
smash the likes comment below share
about
it on your social media tell your
friends we'll repost you
on our at bloodbath girls instagram
bloodbathgirls
follow us on the gram
and we'll be back with more disgusting
[Music]
it really was i mean you did handle it
worse as someone that has grown up with
it
and that's why i'm so sorely
disappointed in myself is like i know
for sure
esther's gonna go down for this one and
she didn't she actually
stood proud well i can't believe i even
licked it like i was it was a hard no
but bobby was [ __ ] screaming at me
and scaring me i'm gonna order some i'm
gonna get something you know what you
might
try durian candy it's not as strong
leave me out of it
yeah see you guys guys please follow us
on instagram or something
i want to apologize for esther
[Music]
you